good morning it gets to say so on Friday
us nerdfighters to share their problems
with us and with each other and they did
so and I am here to help as the poet
hath wrote if you got a problem yo I'll
solve it let's get right to it my laptop
overheats so I can't play games you
probably just need to clean your
laptop's fan but if that doesn't work
behold a beautiful $20 cooling pad I
feel that spiders are a big problem in
the world well the lack of spiders would
be a much bigger problem but anyway the
solution to your problem is 192 pages
long and it is beautiful and it is
called Charlotte's Web read it
immediately I'm scared of the dark
yeah as well you should be it's
terrifying just be grateful you're not a
vampire my biggest problem is my sister
she is annoying and a vampire yeah well
to be fair she's probably annoying
because she's a vampire vampires don't
have it easy even the sparkly kind have
their struggles so you have to find a
way to put yourself and your sisters
vampiric shoes the two keys to sibling
vampiric relationships number one
empathy number two no biting I hate when
you're about to sit on the one seat left
on the bus and then someone takes the
seat right so the thing to do in that
situation is to assume even if it's
improbable that that person needs the
seat more than you do it may not be true
but it will be very helpful to you in
terms of keeping sane particularly like
in parking lots around Christmas my
clothes dryer just set off my fire alarm
dear alarm work better okay so I'm just
gonna throw this out there I'd be more
worried about the dryer than the alarm
because it seems to me that the alarm is
working perfectly I never know what to
do and I always invent a reason not to
do stuff yeah this is a common problem
because the easiest thing for us to do
is the thing that we are currently doing
which is usually nothing but I have
three quick suggestions one go to an art
museum by yourself to read some poetry 3
using Google Maps find a nearby park
that has some walking trails and then
walk around them doing amateur
bird-watching but inventing names for
each of the birds you discover my cat's
latke is broken
oh god panic no just kidding if you have
a Mac you can disable your cap select
button in System Preferences and if you
have a PC you should get the free
application key tweek link in the
dooblydoo
I have stairs that have an open space
between the steps and I'm scared
someone's gonna grab my ankles yeah I'm
not sure I see that it's a problem let's
suppose somebody does grab your ankles
all they have is your ankle you can
still reach into your pocket and call
9-1-1 and if in the mean time they want
to come get you they have to come out
from under the staircase and run up the
stairs during which time you can
the stairs lock the door on them and
leave them there until the police come
frankly of all the possible home
intruder outcomes grabbed by the ankle
it's like the best the book store in my
mouth closed down and it was replaced by
an eyebrow design store
wow that is depressing I have two
solutions first design your own eyebrows
and second buy books at bookstores if
you want bookstores to exist support
them the way that you spend your money
shapes the world in which we live
hufflepuff discrimination yeah I know
right but hopeful puffs don't care my
problem is a lack of community for
beginning writers check out Figment comm
link in the doobly-doo it's much easier
to watch from afar than to participate
in things that's true but it's a lot
more fun to participate so here are
three easy ways to be nerd fight astok
one if you haven't joined keep it or you
can still make your first loan to an
entrepreneur in the developing world for
free there is a link
whoa-whoa-whoa-whoa-whoa link in the
doobly-doo almost went down there but I
didn't - you can read Fahrenheit 451 and
three why not take a few minutes to
respond to some comments with niceness
being nice is surprisingly entertaining
I have spelling problems that limit how
nerdy I can be I totally disagree with
your premise my brother is a terrible
speller and a tremendous nerd I'm an
older nerdfighter yeah so am I to help
you feel less alone I have created a
Facebook group for us there's a link in
the doobly-doo I can't find nerdfighters
who live in my area you should move on
Facebook and in the Ning and in your
pants context is everything because
there are a lot of location specific
nerdfighter groups I have a slight fear
of being drowned by mermaids nah don't
worry about that you'll be fine well
until the human voices wake you Hank
I'll see you on Friday